The sauce,
Kevin here with a game so complex and so important that
it's the basis for an entire five day course on strategic
thinking.
This is it, that's it. What is this?
Welcome to the El game developed by Edward DeBono over 50 years
ago,
the L game was designed to be the simplest possible game that could stretch the
player's ability to find not just any solution,
but the best solution in a constantly changing environment.
Here's how it works. The Elle game only has a handful of pieces,
a very tiny board and hardly any rules.
And it's deliberately indeterminate,
meaning that two perfect players could theoretically play
forever with no winner. And there's a point to that.
Let's look at the board.
It's just a four by four grid and each player has a single
L shaped piece that takes up four total spaces.
There are also two neutral pieces.
These pennies that can be moved by either player.
And we start the game by nestling the two L's in the center and putting the
neutral pennies in the top left and the bottom right corners.
So get ready to L each player is required to move their
LPs into a new unoccupied spot on the board,
by picking it up.
And moving it, flipping it, twisting it, turning it.
Whatever. As long as it cleanly occupies four squares.
So like this, or like this, not like this,
or like this it's, you can't do that.
That doesn't work.
As long as at least one square is new and it doesn't
overlap with the other LPs or a neutral spot.
Then the move is legal. After that move,
the player can choose to move either neutral piece to an open space
or not. It's totally up to you whether you want to play defense,
but you can't move the neutral piece before you move
your L the only object of the game is to make it so that the other player
can't move their LPs. If they can't move, then you win.
Like if our pieces were in this position,
I could move my L here and the neutral piece here.
And I, when your L is locked in,
you can't go anywhere. See,
and that's it it's game over. It seems so easy.
So how can this game possibly take five days to master
consider the following board position,
which DeBono uses in his 1967 book five day course in
which is actually three, five day courses. The L game is just one of them.
I'll be player one pink, and you'll be player two orange.
I only have three possible moves here. Uh, let me show you.
It's not that difficult to choose one, right wrong.
Choosing a legal move is easy.
Choosing the best move isn't I need to think about what's likely to happen
after I make my move. What will you do on the next turn?
And what kind of board position will you put me in for my next move?
Will you play perfectly or will you make a mistake? That gives me an advantage.
And if that's what I have to consider to make the best move,
what do you need to think?
It seems impossible to know,
and that difficulty is at the heart of DeBono, strategic thinking.
You can employ a few basic strategies to survive and conquer,
like blocking off a three by three grid in the corner of a board using
your L and a neutral piece,
and then manipulating the other neutral piece to eliminate your opponents
possibly.
Or you can think about the grid as two halves and lock your opponent.
In one half of the grid,
Those strategies are pretty good, but they're far from perfect.
Let's go back to my earlier scenario, given my three possible moves.
You have countermoves for each counters,
a and B both result in a loss for me,
because there's just nowhere for me to put my L because remember the neutral
spot can only be moved after a player moves.
The LPs countermoves C is my best possible move because I'm
not locked in. I don't automatically lose with C.
The trick is whether I can see this coming in advance so
that I can avoid taking the L alright, got it.
Three moves. Think ahead. No big deal.
But what if we have this situation?
This has 195 possible moves
with only one of them being the best at one out of
195. Awesome.
Given the confines of the board,
there are 82 possible positions for the L pieces and
2,296 board States all together.
DeBono teaches that we should learn how to think about the L game
by mentally ranking a move in one of four ways
fatal in which your opponent wins on the next move week,
which leads you into a defensive position, neutral,
which changes nothing for either player and strong,
which gives you the advantage in this position.
There are 65 possible moves. 22 are fatal.
17 are week 26 neutral.
And zero strong. Okay?
When you consider all those possibilities and keep track of them
two or three moves down the line, perfect play entails,
collecting and evaluating every possible move and making the best choice
based on those results, which is perfectly impossible.
Even for a human mind, obsessed with Tetra.
Domino's like everyone,
modern humans love Ted traumas,
which are geometric shapes made of four equal squares joined edge to
edge. There are five free Tetra Domino's, which are the basic shapes.
You'll probably recognize from Tetris,
the L square Z line and T and Tetris
also has to [inaudible] of the L and the Z.
They can be shifted, rotated, rejiggered,
or reflected to fit all together,
like in this five by eight grid,
which is one of 99,352 ways that
these pieces can fit within these boundaries
or this four by 10 rectangle,
which can be formed any of 57,472 ways
using Tetra Domino's until Minecraft Tetris was the number one
selling game of all time,
because our brains are fascinated with geometry puzzles and considering the
unknowns, a few moves ahead, or 100,000 moves ahead.
Okay, let's go back to Al on day three of training,
DeBono says that a player can note the positions that made them lose,
and the positions that made the other player,
when that mindset is simple,
you'll eventually learn to avoid the bad spots and put yourself in the good
spots experience matters. And it trains us to think,
but it means it takes time and you'll lose a lot of games along the
way you need strategic principles. And if you want to play it yourself,
I put a link down below to an online version of the L game.
It'll show you how many possible moves you have in each board state and let you
run simulation after simulation to see just how complex this
simple looking game really is to make sense of the impossibility
of calculating every possible move. In real time to bono advocates,
creating a set of several guiding principles that can inform your
strategy,
like always keeping a neutral piece adjacent to your
LPs or taking corner positions whenever you
can. There aren't any magic answers.
Possibilities here are endless,
but your strategic principles informed by your experience are
essentially shortcuts to success,
allowing you to avoid playing 10 million L games or considering
every single possible move.
The more you play and the better your mental grouping of game situations
develops, the more accurate your guiding strategic principles will be
15 years after de Bono's book came out,
M E Goler devised a simple system that will guarantee a player,
at least an indefinite draw and provide opportunities to win.
If their opponent makes a mistake,
if you can get your LP so that it occupies three of the four
central squares in the grid,
or so it occupies two central squares and no neutral piece occupies
any of the squares marked X you're in good shape to not
lose beyond that.
It's up to you to use your strategic thinking skills,
to win the game in an academic mathematical game.
You could spend a few years working out all the moves and ranking their
utility, but in real life,
when you're sitting across the table from the other player,
just like your sitting across the table from me, you can't take forever.
You got to make a move.
And the player who can accurately think the furthest in advance is
going to win,
which is what we all do every day in our own ways in
our own lives.
Today is another day in our never ending course on
strategic thinking.
We don't rotate ELLs on a board,
but we do envision the future and alter our decisions in the
present to give ourselves the best opportunity to succeed.
We break down our life boards into smaller,
more manageable sections and create little systems based on what we've
learned and what we've come to value.
We gain experience and make shortcuts to give us the
optimal chance to avoid ELLs and
manifest.
Double use. And as always,
thanks for watching.